but Marsha Mason appeared in Neil
Simon's new play on Broadway
she won rave reviews and Neil Simon a
man who wrote such trifles as come blow
your horn barefoot in the park The Odd
Couple plays oh sweet sweet Saturday
sometime a few others it's their year
and our pleasure to have them present
the next award
and the playwright of the Western world
the nominees for the best story in
screenplay based on factual material now
previously published are produced are
George Lucas Gloria Katz and Willard
Huyck four American Graffiti Ingmar
Bergman for cries and whispers Steve
shaken for save the tiger
David s Ward for the sting Melvin Frank
and Jack Rose for a touch of class oh we
got mail cute
the winner is David s Ward for the
school
thank you there are a lot of people to
thank for this I think the Academy is
thank most of them forming with their
nominations so I would like to thank all
the people who've gone to and supported
the sting and all the people who support
movies in general because without them
none of us would be there thank you